while some of your worst behavior over
the board as a kid ah there are there
many things but I think the main thing
is not handling loss as well just
screaming or not computable for probably
think along with quite a gentleman I
once read the book and the table
my father was generally very gentle with
me but I got a very serious talking to
after that he came to pick me up from
the club and he saw that and he he was
not impressed it was a very good book
but that doesn't excuse anything I've
had sleep last night
after saffle office does not I recommend
straight this is just a chess game you
know it's an art but it's not to be
taken that seriously okay I remember one
case where I after I lost the game I was
very sorry I'm Sigma phones half and
this was in Budapest I was probably
Brian ten years old I think I was an I
am you know he was a veteran player is a
very strong player for many years and
obviously was very disrespectful to him
and after the game he came up he told my
coach and my father that and I just I
remember remember that very distinctly
and it since then I've always shaken my
phone's hand win a roofer had least
tried to
even if I'm very upset about a game and
obviously whatever any clear losers are
doing so to not you know show it out
week toward my volunteers it's not their
fault it's my fault that I lost when I
was little I blundered my queen I mean I
let go of a pit I told my opponent that
didn't happen because I had a completely
winning position and then i blundered
this yeah well the arbiter wasn't there
from my plants was extremely obsessed
they get away with this but this for me
with a lesson it's never too so I don't
know in Norway kids are very well
behaved
you